towns are cut off roads are blocked and
communities are stranded after days of
heavy rain more wet weather is on its
way with three states in eastern
Australia bracing for further flooding
this is a pretty bad flood and the
damage is going to cause now
to the roadways and everything else
we've just got out of covert we've
already got a big bill for that now
we've got another big Bill to do all the
repairs dams are full
and the ground or much of the East Coast
has been saturated so the rainfall that
falls has no capacity to be absorbed
into the soil it's running straight into
rivers and we're starting to see those
Rivers respond to the heavy rainfall
yesterday and overnight Melbourne is
expecting its most intense weather event
of the Year this week and Sydney has
recorded its wettest year on record with
torrential rain forecasts as Australia
rides out its third consecutive La Nina
event the really uh unfortunate thing
about having La Nina events back to back
is that if you get one year of intense
rain and flooding you fill up your dams
the soil is saturated with water and um
then if you have a subsequent year of
heavy rainfall it's much you need a lot
less rain to cause a flood so it's a lot
more damaging to have these events back
to back it may be sunny here in
Queensland but the Bureau of
meteorology's long range forecast
predicts that much of eastern Australia
will be hit with above average rainfall
in coming months its latest National
report also shows that climate change is
influencing Australia's weather and
these rain events are the results
the La Nina which delivers heavy
rainfall is predicted to last into the
southern hemispheres summer months the
forecast predicts the wet weather won't
dissipate until February next year Sarah
Clark Al Jazeera Brisbane Australia